ready to go
thank you as chair of the house ways and
means committee i find that
due to the state of emergency declared
by the governor
as a result of the corporate 19 pandemic
and according to house rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a work session on revenue please
note that there is no physical location
for members of the public to observe and
listen contemporariously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate
contemporariously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform
and the public has access to
contemporaries
listen and if necessary participate in
this meeting
by the zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies the
house schools rsa
91-a anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting should call
[Music]
27-271-3600
or email hcs leg.state.nh.edu
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that are
on the meeting assisting us
jennifer for committee research
researchers please note that all votes
that are taken during this meeting
should be done by roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance
when each member states they're present
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you
during this meeting which is required
under the right to know law
so representative bernstein if you take
the rules
thank you mr chair good morning everyone
it is
on april 28 2021 it is 10 05 a.m we'll
begin roll call with representative
abrami
yes i'm here in my home alone in
stratham thank you
representative mary griffin
representative jordan home in the office
in hudson janice is in the house
someplace
tell her i said hello representative
ober
karen hudson with the usual group of six
representative ducette i'm on my mobile
device in salem soon to be back in my
home office
about four minutes thanks your clerk is
alan burstein
i'm in my home office in nottingham new
hampshire representative elliott
i'm here in salem new hampshire at my
daughter's house there's no one else in
the home
except me representative gennady
representative nunes
representative baxter thank you mr clerk
i'm still in florida
i'm alone right now but there may be
people that enter and good morning to
you
good morning representative spillsberry
good morning i'm home in charlestown my
wife is elsewhere in the home
representative tudor good morning i'm
home in northwood the wife and grandkids
are upstairs
representative army good morning
uh i'm home in lebanon hello senator
ames
yes i'm here in jeffrey uh alone in my
home office
representative southworth here in dover
alone representative malloy here
in greenland alone representative thomas
schamberg thank you representative
berstein
i'm here in wilmette in my office and my
wife is in her office
representative tucker i'm here
in randolph alone representative
good morning i am present and alone good
morning representative hacken phillips
good morning i am present in my concord
office alone
representative james murphy good morning
i am alone in my home office in hanover
good morning and our chairman
representative norman major
good morning i'm in my home in posto and
my wife is in the house
mr chair there are 20 members present
for our absent
thank you representative bernstein
uh christopher shea and are you with us
i am represent how are you this morning
i am doing fine
would you um go through
the agenda for the morning
yeah so um this morning you should have
received two emails from me
one had the typical worksheet that you
used to do your revenue estimates
an excel file and a pdf file and then a
second
email was where i provided you with the
agencies that the senate ways and means
has dealt with to date
so there was three agency documents that
i sent you as well as the
website that you can find that
information
so the first thing that i i need to let
you know is that there is a
mistake on the worksheet i sent you i'm
going to screen share and just show you
where that is
so on the um worksheet there's the tab
this dra high low estimate so i filled
in the information that you're going to
be hearing from dra about today but i
failed to
show you the percent changes on row five
on the business taxes on this screenshot
you have right now you see it's two six
and then three five for 23.
um i think on the old document you have
the the prior numbers
so once we're done today i'll send out a
revised worksheet to
the committee so this is page three
um of the pdf file yep
and then the only other i mean it's the
typical worksheet
i tried to uh eliminate some rows that i
thought you didn't need anymore so i got
rid of fiscal year 2021 to help
consolidate
you know what you have on the page
but it left the agency information from
january and then
where the committee had agreed to
estimates on february 23rd
and then again on march 18th i left
those in the worksheet as well
and then um just bolded the lines of the
new agency estimates and then the
committee agreed to estimates this time
around
and then just to briefly kind of bring
you up to date
on the three agencies that have
presented to
senate ways and means it was liquor
commission lottery commission
and the bureau of securities
the liquor commission um actually came
in with higher revenue estimates than
what you see
on this document so the last time they
met with this committee it was 129
million
in um fiscal year 2021.
they presented the senate ways in means
a number of 133
point 1 million for fiscal year 21
and then for fiscal year 22 they went
from 138 to 141.6 million
and then for fiscal year 23 they went
from 138 million to 141.2 million
so that would be in the document and
i'll populate this um
once we're done today the uh securities
revenue
had no change when they came in the
bureau securities uh
director glennon had no changes to the
estimates and if you're paying attention
to the daily revenues that are being
sent out
you'll notice that securities is is not
in yet
typically securities is a transfer
that's made at the end of the month
and sometimes what happens is you don't
catch that in the daily revenues
worksheets that get sent out to the
committee because it sometimes falls on
the very last day of the month but the
transaction in the system doesn't occur
until the first day of the next month so
uh director glennon didn't indicate
there were any issues with collecting
revenue it's just a timing issue
and then the only other two other things
is the lottery revenue
um the only change that charlie made was
that he came up in his revenue estimate
for uh 2021 so he's now suggesting that
they'll be closer to 128 million
and left 22 and 23 125 and 127.5
but i just thought it was good for the
committee to know that because you're
you had estimated 130.6
based on some trending that you had
discussed
and so now charlie seems to be getting
closer to that number as well
and you sent these reports from these
three
agencies to us this morning i did i did
and and
i also uh provided the link where you
would find them in our on the website so
similar to where your documents are if
you go to our website
you'll see house um a link to the house
documents there's going to be a link to
the senate documents as well
so um if you you know next monday after
committees meet if you want to see
um who presented the senate ways and
means and what was said you can go there
and find that
for instance i didn't share with the
committee the um discussion that um
mr artinger had with the senate ways and
means this past monday
um but the the presentation is available
if you want to go look at that
and then the only the only other piece
that i wanted to bring up was tobacco
settlement
you had an estimate of 38.4 million
based on the discussions with the
department of justice
and if you've been looking at the daily
revenue you're going to see that the
amount that the state actually received
was 47.8 million
and um the the
mr sisson from the department of justice
is they're still looking at why the
number is higher but as he indicated to
this committee
back in january through a letter um
the the settlement is is agreed upon
uh national sales of the participating
manufacturers
um and then there's certain percentages
that each state will get re
as a result of that um
it's not a direct link to your tobacco
um in column c or eat if any document
you're looking at
just because your tobacco is in sales in
new hampshire are up that's not why your
tobacco settlement is necessarily
up because it's based on the national
sales and it has to do with
participating and non-participating
members of the settlement agreement so i
just want to make sure to draw that link
don't just assume that because it's high
this year that the next two years will
also be high
there may be some trend reasons why and
um the doj
doj will be looking at that as part of
the work they do with the master
settlement
and you said that was 47.8 yes
wow 9 million more
yep
any questions of chris on this
so stop share
so that's really all i had for the
committee um really you want to talk to
once if
once i address your questions i mean dra
is going to give you a good rundown of
what's been going on with the the
majority of the taxes that i think
are really the the uh the ones you need
to be concerned about
okay questions for chris uh
representative brownlee
followed by representative early and al
almighty
chair uh chris oh thanks uh on
what way to the tobacco settlement um
such a increase this year uh
obviously they're looking at it you said
uh will they be joining us or will they
get through you
their their reasoning for why it was
high and um
as well as any changes that they may
make for next year
so that they're um supposed to be
providing a letter to senate ways and
means
on what they think will happen with the
um settlement going forward
so that i was going to use that and
share that with this committee instead
of
making several requests requests of the
same individual for different committees
um but i'm not sure based on
conversations earlier this year when we
were trying to get information for your
committee
i'm not sure that they're going to have
a lot of uh ability to make changes to
what's forecasted in 22 and 23
because it takes time for them to go
through the you know the um
the calculation the audit that's done on
the calculation and then determine why
um the amount was what it was
and will that continue to trend out in
the next two years
so i think that's why i would advise at
this time i wouldn't make any uh
adjustments to um your tobacco
settlement numbers
other than 21. exactly exactly because
that's in the door that's in the bank
right now
okay thank you uh representing early
yes thank you chris for taking the
question
um the governor's estimates are closer
to the actuals
than our our estimates so i'm just
curious did he have uh
information that was not available to
either the house or senate
at the time he brought his estimates
together is there
you know within a couple of million
overall estimates you're discussing yeah
he's 240
or he's 251 versus 247.
it was on the sheet you just showed
are you oh you're looking at uh tobacco
revenue
yeah okay sorry sorry you i thought you
you were talking about settlement money
i'm like okay that's
the number um not necessarily no
no um they made estimates at a point in
time just as you do
and um as you may recall right after
you completed your estimates in february
the governor
came out with a letter with some revised
estimates
so he he or his team thought there were
some changes to those estimates
it's the best that you can do at a point
in time so i wouldn't say that they had
anything
um more than what this committee had
um i think that you've gotten the same
types of information as the governor's
office also has
and and i think that through our office
and through dra
you get some pretty good real-time
information yeah we do thank uh thank
you i just wanted to
make sure that everyone was aware of
that uh
timing issue um although you can't time
the market you can certainly time your
estimates
reps and help me thank you mr chairman
um back on the tobacco settlement itself
on there is an enormous amount of
litigation that goes
on on huge numbers of issues within the
tobacco settlement
every year keeps and they have huge
numbers of lawyers
on all sides and i'm wondering um
it it sounds to me like that extra money
is probably another of those litigations
having been
temporarily settled they settle on the
year at a time
uh often and on
why the department of justice doesn't
get a heads
up when when this stuff um
comes is going to be coming out has been
resolved
and has been put in well i think
in the past when we've worked with the
department of justice around the tobacco
settlement they have updated the
committee when there has been resolution
on those outstanding issues and they've
also provided updates where they can
but as as you know they're ongoing in
many cases so there may be things that
um as attorneys and and through the
process they cannot share with
with you know outside of that process
until it's complete um
i know mr sisson's job primarily is to
track the
settlement um work with the various
other state attorney generals
and the audit group and the uh
other attorneys for the tobacco
companies to to monitor and make sure
that everybody gets their fair share on
this
um so as you noted it's a fairly
complicated process
um when mr sisson can provide some
updated information and if it's valuable
enough to
move it forward you know we'll certainly
share it with the committee
but um
as you know it's really right up until
the minute that they start to get checks
that can
when i talked to him at the beginning of
april to find out how much we were
getting
he would he he hesitated to provide a
number because he still wasn't sure
and not until the first check came
through the door did he
you know say yeah it looks like we're
going to get maybe this amount but
wait let's make sure the second check
gets in and it is that amount
so there's a lot of things i'm not aware
of obviously so i i
again i think it's um you know we rely
on the
department of justice attorneys and that
are assigned to the master settlement
agreement to provide information
and uh to the best of their ability
what makes it really complicated is that
there's
two major issues one has to do with the
participating manufacturers
that participating manufacturers in the
sale their cigarettes
is volatile and then the
non-participating manufacturers
is also volatile and to try to
figure out the right percentages from
participating and
non-participating adding to adding them
together
and they're arguing with all the
attorneys from both sides it makes it
very
difficult
i see reps of abrami has his hand up
and rips okay thank you mr chair uh
chris i'm back to securities yep well if
that that last
payment doesn't make it by friday and
let's say it comes in monday or tuesday
but that will be treated as april
revenue correct
no it would probably show up in the uh
may revenue
it will okay it it's that's quite a it's
a 16.7
uh variance
but it so
what the concern is really your yearly
revenue i mean
you know the the the state divides up on
a monthly basis you know what they
anticipate
receiving um but as long as the revenue
is trending to meet the plan that the
state
the year plan i think that's the bigger
issue to pay attention to than whether
you got it in april or may
as long as it comes in the door if you
don't get it either day
or either month excuse me that's the
bigger concern
why why isn't the money coming in you
know it was anticipated in april we
didn't see it in may why
um but as i indicated uh director
glennon had had stated to the senate
ways and means earlier this week that
revenues are on track with what he's
estimated
right so what you're saying it'll it if
it misses it'll probably be amazing
we look at the revenue focus
and and the revenue focus would note
that okay whatever
so that in the narrative part of the the
revenue focus there would probably be a
comment that would you know basically
say that
um you know due to timing you know the
the bounce is going to show up in the
next month but
you know everything came in like it
should have ready
thank you yep just our question i have
chris yep eight point
six million dollars was that that came
in extra
is that primarily from the
non-participating manufacturers
i don't know the split on um how the
revenue
is attributed city uh
the citibank is is the uh
depositor of the money and and they did
it in
two over two weeks why they split it the
way they did i don't have an answer to
that i'd have to uh get that from
department of justice
but it's always been split or at least
the last couple of years i know it's
been in over two payments that they've
done that i don't know why though
it represents early
yeah thank you um with attack excuse me
with the tax
being delayed another month how is that
going to affect the ind
revenue coming in is or is it going to
have an effect at all i know
another month although taxes are
supposed to be paid by last week
right so so the delay is a it's on the
federal return
for an individual the new hampshire new
hampshire didn't delay its return so you
should have paid your taxes on time
but i would defer or would ask you to
allow dra to respond to that they would
have a better sense but i
i think the the answer i can give you is
i i don't know if there's been a delay
or
as a result of the federal government
pushing it out a month
okay thank you sir representative
thank you um back to the tobacco
settlement the
third thing that on i think still
varies is that uh there are penalties
for
states that don't do sufficient
enforcement against
illegal cigarettes and um
there are places like new york where
illegal cigarettes are all over the
place
on and when they lose money because of
because of that do the rest of us gain
in that formula or is that a
it just stays in a reserve fund or goes
back to the
manufacturers so i don't know a direct
answer to that question reps of only but
in the letter that mr sisson provided
back in january
21st 2021 he made he
in the middle paragraph he says the
payments there's three things that
can have an impact on your payments the
payments are adjusted upwards at an
agreed rate of inflation
the the payments are adjusted downward
based on decreases in the national
market for cigarettes
and downward again to reflect the
markets movement away from the premium
brand cigarettes towards discounted
uh non-participating uh manufacturers
who have not joined the msa
so those were the three things that in
january that mr assistant identified
would have a potential
impact on how you calculate what amount
comes into the state
so i don't know how the enforcement
would fit figure into that
do we have an issue on
excuse me do we have another
issue dealing with other revenues that
you want to ask chris about
if if no one does represent major i did
have one thing i forgot to mention about
liquor
okay um so though they've
estimated an increase as you may recall
when they came in
um during their time with the house ways
and means committee they
indicated they had to pay out an extra
8.2 million dollars to
new hampshire grant and advantage based
on rsa 126
dash aaa colon 3 so that statute allows
for the department of health and human
services if they're having a shortfall
in the in that fund to request liquor
commission make a transfer to it
and at that time there was no indication
that there would be another one in
in fiscal year uh 21. however
at the end of march the department of
health and human services did reach out
to
liquor commission and indicated in the
next six month period so that would be
um the last three months of 21 and then
the first three months of fiscal year 22
they potentially may need another
transfer from the liquor commission
of an amount less than 8.2 million but
they don't know the amount yet
so i've um trying to work with health
and human services to see if we can get
some information related to that
um but i just wanted to make you aware
that um
there may be another hit to the to the
liquor commission revenue and i just
don't know if it's going to be
um in 21 or 22 yet i kind of think it's
going to probably come into
22 unless they do something quickly when
did that start
what year did that start right this is
the first year that this is occurring i
think it was in legislation past last
year that they
um that the language was adjusted to
allow for this to occur
and the first time you saw an impact was
uh in january
february time frame when when uh liquor
commission came in and indicated they
had to make that transfer a way of
bypassing the legislative process
pushing
reps of almighty has their hand done
thank you i i think that that was in the
final
budget to to have a safety valve if
there was going to be
more um more medicaid expenses
than they'd budgeted for
that it was going to come out of liquor
i didn't find it particularly lovely but
it was something that that made sense to
the senate
the legislation could have come out
i think it was in the budget itself
and it didn't show up until recently
because
they were going through the money that
they had in the budget
oh boy i hope you don't see much more
okay any further questions for chris
then uh the dra is here with
carolyn devin
melissa took a lot of men
well thank you everybody i'll remain on
the call if after they're done if
there's anything you need me for
good thank you
carolyn on the way
administration revised revenue estimates
dated april 28th which
we'll be using this morning so who's
talking to the dre
good morning mr chair it will be me
melissa rollins senior financial analyst
for the department of revenue
i will also have assistant commissioner
carolyn lear
as my backup to to take any of those
hard-hitting questions
okay i'm going to
attempt to share my screen if you could
give me a minute
yes
okay this is the document everybody
should should have
right so everybody can see it all right
i can see it i have some others
all right so welcome we um are here to
give some updated revenue estimates
we were here um maybe a month or so back
doing
doing the same presentation however
today we are doing revenue estimates
through march we're going to be talking
about or i'm going to be talking about
our major taxes
business profits tax business enterprise
tax meals and rentals tax tobacco tax
interest and dividends tax
communications services tax real estate
real estate
transfer tax and utility property tax
we have in the chart below our fiscal
year 21
revised estimates these are
net of the anomalous receivable i think
at this point the committee's
pretty familiar with that and we know we
need to uh remove those
anomalous receivables so we can have a
nice solid base to grow
fiscal year 22 off from and then
we will also be presenting revised
fiscal year 22
in fiscal year 23 growth ranges in the
chart
you will see under business taxes and
interest and dividends tax we have
tbd to be determined uh as you know
right now we are in the middle of
or getting close to the end of the bulk
of the revenue coming in for those taxes
we're receiving uh returns right now for
covid periods
and we really wanted to make sure we got
all of that revenue
in those tax return process so we could
do a deeper dive and
really understand what's going on and
why the revenues are so high
for business taxes this month and i
believe we'll be coming back
in may to give you um updated
estimates on those taxes uh which would
include
march and april we're looking forward to
that
great us as well us as well
um also on this page i just want to draw
your attention to what you're pretty
familiar with
um some taxes have fared pretty well
during this pandemic as you can see that
with
um we have
tobacco tax at 22 um
we have real estate transfer tax at 30
ahead of plan and then other taxes have
not fared as well
and as you know meals and rentals tax
has been one of the hardest hit taxes
through this pandemic at a loss of 17
percent
all right moving on to business taxes
just give you an update of where we were
at through march
fiscal year to date through march we
were 100.7 million or 21
ahead of plan and 113.1 million
or 24.2 percent ahead of prior year
this does include an 18.3 million dollar
anomalous receivable
as you know and i just stated effects on
this
um effects on kovid 19 for the business
tax
we're seeing that now in our march and
april returns so what's due in march and
april are calendar year filers
for calendar year 2020. um
so this will be again will be
interesting to see how these
pan out and what they look like once
everything is posted
i do want to note though that we may
have an increase in extension payments
that are happening this year
and we won't get actual data on those
returns for extension payments for seven
months so in the fall we will get
the full picture for calendar year
filers of what's what
what happened in 2020 on these these
returns
another thing that we thought was
important to consider is that
uh this session we have had the largest
stimulus package the federal government
has ever
infused into the economy it's just less
than
25 of the 2019 gdp
which is incredibly incredibly large and
we really
think that those large stimulus packages
have really
helped carry businesses along it has
helped individuals
with consumer spending and helping
what's in their bank accounts
and it's just really something to keep
in mind as to why we may be ahead so far
and lastly we just wanted to know
unemployment rates obviously those have
fluctuated as well as just
how the economy is performing in in
general is definitely tied to how
business taxes are performing
in the second column in in the next
chart
we show fiscal year to date for business
taxes we're 561.6 million dollars of
revenue in so far and that's 17.2
ahead of plan and then for our fiscal
year 22 ranges i believe we did adjust
these some from when we were last here
we expanded a bit we now have a range of
two to six percent uh for fiscal year 22
and three to five percent for fiscal
year 23.
these growth ranges are based on
predicted gdp
um it varies on which sites you look at
uh the average right now we've seen is
around five percent but it is lower on
some sites and higher on
other sites and then what we have heard
in general
across the board is that they do
anticipate the gdp to slow during fiscal
year 23
to around four percent again that can
vary some depending on the websites but
that is encompassed in our range
[Music]
any questions on business taxes through
march
any questions from the committee members
actually norm i i can't find my button
here so
okay what representative broadway yeah i
think
i don't know when you want to have this
discussion uh mr chair about uh
how we want to how we want to project
for future years i guess it depends on
whether we pass
sb3 or not um
if we if we do then
there's some of this revenue and i know
dra is going to be working on this
we have to try to best estimate how much
of the revenue from this year is really
i guess anomalous uh that is going to
have to be given back in the next two
years
so uh so is the strategy to continue to
predict
revenues as they offer 21
without any modification
and then uh and then we have a
discussion about
how much of that would be an anomalous
like we have in the past
that we can pass along to the senate and
others that don't don't spend this money
because we're giving some of it back so
i i
that's my only concern going forward as
to how we're going to handle that
and yeah we can have that discussion now
or later but
i think we need to have that discussion
that's my big concern
that's why i'm not in a hurry on senate
bill 3.
we have a lot of work to do on senate
bill 3 to try to identify
how much of that excess
business taxes is associated with
the stimulus funds that are out there
and then how much is is it going to
fluctuate
do if we pass senate bill 3 as
is because under current law
they don't get a credit for that because
if they use
the stimulus funds for what it was
intended to they're not going to get
taxed on it anyway
so we need to number one find out
how much is it going to affect our
revenues
if we pass senate bill 3 as is
and then we're going to have to make a
determination do we want to do that or
not
so that's why i figure that's going to
take us a while and we're going to
stretch it right out to the end
to to the point where we have to make a
determination
of what we estimate the revenues are
it's going to be our most difficult task
sounds good also something that's going
to affect
revenues is whether or not
um house bill 2 goes
through as is is
if house bill 2 or if the budget goes
through as
is and if it looks like that
then we know what those numbers would be
but if not then we would have to make
adjustments on that
at least tell them what the effect would
be
so we have a lot of work to do
especially with the business taxes
understanding how much of that is
associated
with the stimulus how much of that is
associated with
uh forgiving
the forgiving the loans
in addition to being able to writing it
off
so i hope that answers that question
sure does thank you representative
thank you mr chairman i'd like to ask
melissa or
carolyn maybe on when they think
with how much more information do they
think that they will have about
these issues by the 26th of may
which is the last date we can get it to
vote the next day
i can start with that and if carolyn
wants to supplement um
feel free um so right now like i said
returns are coming in for calendar year
filers so i think
um by the beginning or mid-may
we'll be able to look at these taxpayers
that have
filed um it's honest it's called a
schedule for so we have a separate line
item on a schedule for these ppp
information
so at least for the taxpayers that are
actually filing returns in march and
april and have reported
that ppp information we will be able to
have
that for you before the end of may
if i could on i think that we were told
yesterday that
uh by by uh
carolyn i think unknown by lindsay that
on a lot of the businesses
are likely that got ppp loans
may be filing extensions so
we won't be able to look at their
information
and i think that's a fair statement i
did take a peek yesterday at extensions
to see what the counts were looking
looking like and return counts were down
and extension counts were up
so um as commissioner sepp did say
yesterday i think that
is fair that again we can analyze what
has
i could jump in on this is that the
filing of the taxes for april
in may march and april is primarily due
to the tax year
2020 and tax year 2020
is our concern on the first stimulus
package
which had the ppp loans the second
set of ppp loans was not authorized
until january of this year
and so for tax year 21
we will see that effect
in what's filed in march in april of
2022 so we're going to go through the
whole process again for that and
so um i know that the dra
has combined the two together and
came up with about 91 million dollars in
total effect
but we need to be able to understand how
much of that is due to the first
stimulus package
and how much the second stimulus package
can contribute to that that's just one
part of the pie the other part of the
pie is
and and i'm trying to get somebody from
treasury
who understands what's happening in
to let us know how
this stimulus package this
huge stimulus package has been passed
but the rules haven't been written yet
is how can we use that
funds if we can use that funds for
supplementing if we allow
the first stimulus
ppp loans to be forgiven so they get
double benefits
to backfill that we have to make a
decision on that
but we we can't even discuss that until
we know what the rules are
i'm afraid there's going to be a lot on
sensei afraid
we need to be aware of what the rules
are
and that 1.9 trillion dollar stimulus
package and
what the states can use to backfill
and i know there's a bunch of states
that are telling the federal government
you can't do what you said initially is
that you can't
back till you know or change your tax
rates because of this
so that's all up in here
you have anything to add on melissa
i think everything that you said um is
definitely accurate
are 22 and 23 estimates just to the
growth ranges are based on current law
and i believe if sb3 is passed it does
go into the surplus statement as a
reduction
um for future years
we need to understand this so that we
can
warn the rest of our colleagues
that this money isn't out there to be
spent right away
because if we spend
it
and and then the
essentially it passes then the
refunds are going to be asked for
after all the the extensions are
completed in the fall and we'd have to
give that money back
so we spent money we didn't really have
so we've got to understand that
mr chairman but i was asking about the
uh fy20 results that were
were are in um
fy 21 at this point which
is uh how many of those were actually
forgiven
we don't know and probably a lot of them
are going to be an
extension so we won't know till the fall
whether they were
were went into 21 or they're going into
22.
all right that's all part of the picture
represent a tucker yes i
i wondered whether you could comment uh
miss rollins on
number the fourth listed as a factor
largest stimulus packages the federal
government probably should say as
yet has ever infused into the economy
have you done a sort of a
a little study of what would have
happened
to our businesses here in new hampshire
with 500 or fewer employees
if we hadn't had the packages
somehow i think that it would give us a
different feeling
about sb3 if we understood what
we would be dealing with in the way of
revenues
if we hadn't had those packages
has the department had a moment to think
about that
thanks for your question representative
tucker we um
have not done any implicit
analysis on these federal stimulus
packages
anecdotally we have attended quite a few
webinars on
how these federal stimulus funds have
affected businesses and the positive
impacts that it has on affecting
businesses
and there's a wide variety right it's
not just businesses it's as well
as individuals receiving these payments
increasing individual payments
um through the stimulus fund also
increases consumer spending
which then helps businesses so it's not
always just a direct correlation to
businesses receiving funds from the
federal government it's also
ties to individuals and their spending
habits based on the extra funds that
they have available to them with this
this money so um we haven't done an
exact correlation to it
but we do exact yep but we do
know that um we have heard from other
state agencies that revenues are up as
well it's obviously
surprising compared to where we were
back june of last year when we were
doing revenue estimates
and anticipating a large loss to where
we are
now um and a big factor
is i think what the federal government's
plan was was to infuse the economy
with a large amount of funds to keep it
whole
and not to to dip into a recession
situation
so i do believe that if we could have
some maybe the fiscal institute
or uh the unh
school of business
could come up with some kind of
understanding of what we would be facing
in the way of
vastly reduced revenues if we hadn't had
the federal government infusing that
money and i think it changes
the view a little on sb3 to really
understand that
and you know it really was a partnership
between
the federal government the state and
these individuals and businesses and it
would be
good to have some clearer picture
that's quantitative to understand that
because i think it will change i
understand
why the senate voted 23 to zip
on their recommendation on that bill
and
i think it changes the view of it to
grasp it
so anything that you can come up with i
would be appreciative
that's the names thank you um
yeah instead of getting back to the
immediate estimating
question that we are struggling with um
it's it's clear to me and i'm sure to
the rest of us that
uh that we really
lack information now we're going to have
more information after dra does that
deep dive
that's been talked about into the
information that is coming in
this month with regard to that
i wonder um with regard to the piece of
it that involves
extension payments where i know that
what the ra
receives is not not
not much more than a number a bottom
line number
uh in other words the amount that the
the entity has decided they need to pay
but they don't give any detail on it i
wonder if
if dra could in some way
do a a questionnaire a poll of some kind
a sample sample a set of questions
to payers of extension payments
that directly asks about this ppp
question and allows us to
dig into that part of the revenue that
is pouring in right now
so that's a question
i'm gonna bounce that over to assistant
commissioner earlier if she doesn't mind
yeah so i mean we've i forget now
the context but we've done
questionnaires in the past from the
department
sort of optional questionnaires and
haven't had the greatest success in
getting responses
but i wonder if a more efficient way to
get answers
wouldn't be to work through the cpas
that are filing the returns
and ask them um whether what their
clients
have been doing um and i can
i can get with commissioner steph and
find out whether
that's something that we'd be
comfortable initiating or
get um you folks in touch with the um
ceo of the cpa society um
to do that directly very great
if it's from you as opposed to us
because our
purposes are slightly different
sometimes yeah
i understand that right so that would be
great to
try to figure that out and if we need to
do something
i'm sure chairman major would be
interested
in knowing what that is and deciding
what to do
you make a good point and it reinforces
what i learned last weekend when
my accountant told me uh
he had an awful lot of his customers
that would get refunds back
because has to
submit their tax returns based on
current law
and it'd be nice to find out from the
accountants
as is that about how much
what kind of percentage of their taxes
that they're paying
is associated with
the pvp loans and they'll give us more
information whether it's
trivial or substantial
and i i hope that the dra
does it separately and i'm going to see
if we can find
a couple of not knowledgeable
cpas that come in before the committee
so we can understand that better
represent almighty thank you
i think i think this is a great idea and
if we went
through the cpa society on
and gave them some time to to ask their
membership
on maybe we could get some kind of
structure on it about on
the businesses that are uh
generally reporting over
over a million dollars of uh
profit versus the ones that are are
generally reporting
uh under 500 000 or less
so that we could sort of look at that
together with the triangle
right and we're going to have to
understand that
we want to get cpas that are give us the
uh
that aren't strictly lobbyists
but uh
um but looking at us what the real story
is
that's why i think that the cpa society
would would give us a broader range of
cpas i think that that at least a lot of
the small
small ones as well as the big ones
belong to that
good point
all right any further questions uh if
not then melissa can continue
all right i'm going to move on to the
next slide
um so meals and rentals tax
we have the historical breakdown up top
just for reference
80 meals 17 room three percent motor
vehicle
vehicle um so again like i said meals
and rooms tax has been
the hardest hit tax during the pandemic
fiscal year to date through march it's
61.7 million
or 20.8 percent below plan
and 45.9 million or 16.3 percent below
prior year
this does include a 1.6 million dollar
anomalous receivable
however some things to factor we know
things are changing out there we have
the covid19
vaccine distribution is occurring as
well as some
increased consumer confidence we have
lifted travel restrictions
so i think we're going to start seeing a
change on this recovery rate as we start
to come out of the pandemic
for fiscal year 21 low
we have 315.4 million
which is 18 below plan so obviously
we're 20.8 currently so this assumes a
gradual improvement during these last
few months of the fiscal year
and we're basing that on consumer
confidence growing
people ready to get out based on the
winter as well as
these continued outdoor dining options
that we did see
um start to happen at the
spring of last year but have now even
expanded further
this year and then our high is ending
17 below plan or 320.4 million
this assumes a faster improvement for
the last few months
um with that consumer confidence coupled
with travel restrictions being lifted
and then consumers just trying to get
back to normal
our fiscal year 22 range is 5 to 10
percent growth over 21 base
our low is equal to fiscal year 18 m r
revenue and our high is equal to around
19 fiscal year 19 m r revenue compared
to 21
and then 23 we have
m and r going back to normal as you know
those who have been around for a while
the historical growth
growth rate for m r is typically around
five percent year over year
so we have this four to six percent that
um depending on where 22 lands
gets us back into our normal range for
meals and rentals
happy to answer any questions on this
tax
representative
uh thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
just as a reminder um the meals part
also includes a lot of prepackaged meals
uh from typical grocery stores i
mentioned that because
my store you know i was selling uh
little packages of wings and things that
are all prepared
and it does seem like that's been very
popular so i didn't know that was
anything
that you had noticed or if that really
is a big percent of the meals tax
don't think we necessarily we have a
breakdown on grocery stores and we could
look to see what the growth rate changes
there because not everything in the
grocery store is taxable but as you
mentioned
um representative southwest those items
are taxable
i think it's a really good point i
brought it up in the past and it's not
necessarily on this slide but
we have seen a pretty interesting shift
in meals and rentals tax
where um operators have been pretty
creative to maintain
some status quo or even just to get
through this pandemic
and they've done that like you said more
takeout options um
they've expanded like we said to outdoor
dining we have more people staying at
airbnbs versus hotels um and just
a lot of creativity through the this um
industry to sort of keep them up and
running so i wouldn't be surprised if we
did see an increase in those type of
prepared meals
um bringing in revenue you're welcome
representative uh thank you for taking
my question
as a percentage of uh news and rooms tax
the airbnb type short-term rentals
what percent of that uh is it and
then i have a follow-up
let me just open i'm not sure if i have
a
total percent
[Music]
um
don't think i have a total percent but
we can we can get that for you
it's essentially our rental agents and i
will look um
we can get back to us in that in an
email of how much they make up
as the whole yeah that bread and
breakfast
and uh rental agents type stuff is that
would that
uh uh be the area sure we have two we
have those
categorized in two separate um
categories so i think i can give those
to you individually as a whole as well
all right the only reason i ask that is
because apparently some of the resort
areas
are banning uh short-term rentals
notably conway last night
interesting
i wonder what the effect on revenues
would be by that
yeah we um it would be curious to see
that
i i do know that rental agents um
rental agents have been performing well
they have been
ahead of prior year whereas hotels have
been taking a loss compared to
last year um and my nice colleague devon
rodrick has
let me know that rental agents make up
3.9 percent of total revenue
for february
thank you you know state law allows
towns to limit short-term
rentals
uh carolyn do you know that information
i i don't know the answer to that
question whether local zoning
laws would permit um outlawing
uh short-term rentals i suspect what
local towns would rely upon is that
um short-term rentals
might constitute a business as opposed
to a uh
residential use of property um and i
think a town's ability to
regulate business versus residential use
is pretty well established
um i suspect that the analysis
representative
thank you just to add to that i think on
you you and patrick and i have been with
the city of portsmouth
in uh summer studies in which they were
talking about
doing that and having done that i think
but um i wanted to
ask about something that's been worrying
me looking at
uh we seem as a state through
in the newspapers at least to be
advertising
uh the state as a place you can come
without a mask without a vaccination and
party and if
we get another major outbreak of that
sort we're going to
be be uh discouraging
all of the people that would love to
travel
but don't uh don't want to take risks
of that sort and i don't know how
we could get a handle on
on whether this could be a problem for
the future or not
but on we are advertising ourselves as
as the the place to come for freedom in
new england
at this point not specifically through
the bea i don't think but
uh through all of the stuff that i
see in the media printed and social
that's a statement right
yeah it's a it's a worry okay
um further questions
if not melissa can go on to the next tax
all right our next tax is tobacco tax um
again we just have a break
a breakdown of the taxes 92 percent
um is of the revenue is cigarette stamps
and eight percent is other tobacco
product
this tax has been performing well um
we've spoke a lot about this tax in pre
previous presentations fiscal year to
date through march were 32.7 million or
21.8 percent ahead of plan
and 31.6 million or 20.9 percent ahead
of prior year
again as we've stated several times the
massachusetts ban on mentally aided
tobacco and other flavor tobacco
products
has been a real windfall for the state
of new hampshire
and we've heard this anecdotally from
other states saying they as well
have seen um an increase in their sales
based on the massachusetts band
for fiscal year 21
we have sort of a tighter range here as
we're ending the fiscal year
we have 240.2 million for our
for our low that's 19 ahead of plan
that's assuming sort of all things
continue as usual
and then for our highest 245.1
that's 22 ahead of plan and again that's
continued with this massachusetts flavor
band
and then potentially some increased
cross-border sales due to uh consumer
confidence and travel restrictions
lifted
for our 22 growth ranges we have a
negative three percent
three percent to zero percent for 22
um this is based on historical
year-over-year reductions
and then we've tempered this and
accounted for any residual offset by
e-cigarettes and the massachusetts
flavor band
and then for fiscal year 23 we have a
negative four percent to negative one
percent um
which is a loss consistent with
historical trends
uh just one other thing i wanted to add
on this tax is
once we do end fiscal year 21 we will
have a full year of the massachusetts
mentholated
band products as well as flavored otp
products
in our revenues which is why you don't
see that continued
increase in 22 because again it's one
full year
of encompassing it and we assume that
will be our new base at that point
happy to answer questions on this tax
before we get to questions
melissa in congress right now
is a law to ban
mental cigarettes nationwide and that's
active in congress right now if that
passes
then that would give us a step function
loss in that tobacco revenues you have
any idea how much that would be
if it passes and it's in fact 1
1 22 then it would certainly affect our
22 and 23 estimates yes thank you
representative major for the question
you're absolutely correct if a band of
mentated products
or flavored otb products was federally
banded
we would see a pretty decent decrease in
our revenues especially since we've had
this bump up in 21
for more cross-border sales due to these
products we don't necessarily
have a number tied to that because on
our reporting
a stamp is a stamp they purchase stamps
with us it doesn't matter the type of
product
they're buying um and this is same with
otp when they're filing the return it
doesn't break out the type of
product whether it's mentholated or not
it's more in sub categories
however we have reached out and we do
have anecdotal evidence that
our increase in what wholesalers and
retailers are seeing
is a pretty massive increase um on the
border
the border towns based on this
mentholated ban
so again if if we did see that pass in
the federal government which i do think
has come up a couple of times and hasn't
made it through
if we do see it we will see a reduction
in our tobacco tax revenue
thank you um representative rodney
yes thank you mr chair um melissa
i think i brought this up a couple of
months ago which
i guess we need to keep an eye on what
massachusetts may do
uh in terms of any legislation to
rescind
this this span on unmenthol cigarettes
because
they may miss the revenue um
i think there were a couple of bills but
maybe maybe within a month we should
take another look at that before we
finalize our revenues to see if
if there's any action on those bills
that's that's more of a statement than i
guess a question i just
any reaction to that be fine
yeah we do get some information on
other states and legislation i haven't
seen anything updated on massachusetts
thus far i do know
that connecticut um does have a bill out
there
banning mentally to products and
flavored products so that's one we were
looking at
but i haven't seen anything updated for
massachusetts yet but
you're accurate it's something that um
should definitely keep an eye on
okay thank you rexella
thank you on can you look at the last 12
months since
or rf fy 20 and see
oh oh that is the fy 20 breakdown that
eight percent is other
tobacco products so it's still
maintaining
the history the breakdown we've been at
before the pandemic
yes it has definitely year over year
grown by it's still a small percent
obviously but
if we have it on our dry dry website the
historical breakdown
for these taxes and otp every year has
been
gaining um by a percentage or two
compared to the total but that is a
fiscal year 20 breakdown
yeah so that the pandemic didn't really
affect that
and we have an e-cig breakdown i mean
it's
a very small amount of money but it's
more tobacco
than the money yeah i think and i'm
going off the top of my head i think it
was around
three million fiscal year to date so far
for fiscal year
um 20 revenues for e-cigarettes
out of the anticipated 240 to 245
million so
small percentage so far and again
we do list that in our monthly um
tobacco reports that we send out
any further questions to ask melissa on
the tobacco tax
i don't see any so melissa you can go on
to the next
text
all right so interest and dividends tax
just like business tax i'll give you an
update um where we're at through
march with um fiscal year 21
to be determined uh fiscal year to date
through march we were 19.1 million or
35 35.9 ahead of plan and 21.3 million
or 41.8 percent ahead of prior year
again this includes the 9.2 million
of anomalous receivable as you know this
tax does have historical year-over-year
swings
it is interest and dividends tax so when
the stock market is
performing well this helps in this tax
helps in this task
we know that more people have money in
the bank
again we talked about the federal
stimulus fund this that
does play into this for individuals um
and this tax appears to be unaffected by
covid19
of course we'll we'll see if that
statement rings true
probably towards the end of may because
as you had brought up i forgot which rep
brought it up but chris
also addressed it the irs did extend
their due date for individuals
to file and pay their returns to may
17th
however new hampshire remains april 15th
but we do know that as we keep talking
about this anomalous receivable
we do know that last year the federal
government also extended their due date
to
july where new hampshire extended it to
june
and we still did get a fair amount of
money and returns filed in july based on
the federal due date
so i think as of right now interest and
dividends tax is down
um but before we can jump the gun and
say it's down and it's trued up payments
i do think we need to see what happens
in may
so fiscal year to date for fiscal year
21 were 63.1
million or 18.6 percent ahead of plan
with the anomalous receivable removed
for our growth ranges for 22 we have
four to six percent this is based on
past performance of the tax coupled with
anticipated gdp
and then in 23 we have a two to four
percent growth range
this is a slowing of the growth based on
past performance
as well as anticipated reduction of gdp
in that 23 period happy to answer any
questions
representative army followed by
representative southwest
i think representative southwest was
first
okay representation uh thank you
just for clarification if this tax
is reduced and repealed will that go in
the surplus
statement so this will be in the front
of the budget as if it was really going
to happen
and then the surplus station will will
correct that
that's correct right here is based on
current law if that does pass then
surplus statement will have that
reduction of revenue for um
22 and 23. so people really need to
have the surplus state statement next to
the budget so to speak
to really understand some of the changes
i'm just thinking of the public
yeah i think that's an accurate
statement your end revenue is your
revenues your projected revenues minus
your surplus state minus or plus your
surplus statement items
thank you representative
thank you mr chairman on
can you check on now
uh or right after april is finished
how how many how much refunds we're
getting
in requests we're getting in this or how
much
better how much overpayment of
last year's tax is showing up
this year yeah sure um we get reports on
that and we can see what it looks like
once all these returns are in and
processed for april
as of right now i don't think there's
anything sitting out there that's
glaring that it's going to be any
massive
refunds but we'll definitely take a look
once everything's processed and let you
know if that will have a major impact or
not
thank you uh any further questions on
the interest and dividend tax
saying none we'll say you can go on to
the next
all right communication services tax uh
fiscal year to date through march where
um
negative 300 000 or one percent below
plan
and um 400 000
or 1.4 percent ahead of prior year
as you know this tax um unemployment
rates can affect this tax
it might um affect a taxpayer's or
excuse me a uh well a taxpayer's ability
to pay this tax which was then result in
a
reduced cst tax also we have the
taxability of voip conferencing and
increased use of product
um offset by some decreased use of voip
for the taxability video conferencing
just to um
let you know that we are still looking
into that it's definitely on our list
we had said we were going to do an audit
and look at these taxpayers to make sure
they are paying tax and that is still is
an ongoing process for fiscal year 21 we
don't have a range on this tax because
it doesn't vary
a lot we have 39.1 million that's
landing us two percent below plan and
that's a loss of two percent for the
remaining months of the year
and then we have it flat for 22 and 23.
again we normally see a decrease in this
tax we're starting to feel like we are
at the low point with this tax and then
any offset
being brought in by um the taxability of
the
video conferencing would net that out to
zero
happy to answer any questions on cst
questions from the committee members on
cst
representative thank you
are you any closer to being able to tell
us
how you what you would tax in the
uh zoom calls the video conferencing
uh yes that's what i was speaking to you
about um before representative elmi
we're definitely our audit division is
working hard on this they're still in
the process
and as soon as we have any additional
information we will share that with the
committee
further questions
see none go on to the real estate
transfer tax
all right real estate transfer tax this
tax
has been performing very well fiscal
year to date through march or 32.8
million or 27 percent ahead of plan
in 27.3 million or 21.5 percent ahead of
prior year
we've noted this before but i'll i'll
say it again just so we don't forget
when looking at fiscal year-to-date
um being that 21.5 ahead of prior year
we do want to note that there was a five
million dollar transfer
transfer this year to the affordable
housing fund that was new that did not
occur last year
so when looking at numbers compared to
prior year
you could add in an additional 5 million
moving us even further ahead of prior
year we also wanted to note
in some items to consider is mortgage
rate interest
um are historically low and seem to be
stable at this point
there's also some creativity with real
estate agents doing virtual home sales
we have
available housing and property values as
factors
and also it's it's important to remember
that there are inventory shortages out
there they keep seeming to get bigger
every month as well of
cost of building supplies being um
more expensive than they have in prior
years and a lower affordability factor
meaning in the beginning of the pandemic
you had interest rates low and home
prices low and now you fast forward a
year later because of all the
competition in a buyer's market
you may have interest rates still low
but hos
housing prices have increased making
what people can afford
a smaller range than maybe they did a
year ago
for fiscal year 21 our um our low is
201.5 million
that's 27 ahead of plan so essentially
that's assuming where we're at today is
going to continue through the rest of
the year
and then our high is 205.7 million
that's 30
ahead of plan and that's in um
saying we're going to have a slight
increase from where we're at today
for our 22 ranges we have a negative 7
to a negative two percent this assumes
that we're going to start strong
in the beginning of the fiscal year as
we are ending the fiscal year strong
and then it's going to be a gradual
shift down of performance less than what
it was for fiscal year 21.
and in 23 um we have negative 10 percent
to negative 8 percent
and this this picture essentially is
assuming historical trends were
maintained through fiscal year 20
through 22 so removing the housing spike
and what's happened today
if we were just continuing to grow
without this blip
um what would it look like and that
would put us negative 10
to negative 8 compared to 22 and this
also falls in line
with economist predictions for what the
housing market look like
will look like during this time frame
are there any questions on real estate
transfer tax
just a question melissa
i think i read yesterday um
that the existing home prices for the
first time
exceed the price of new homes have you
been aware of that article um i haven't
read that yet
i wouldn't be surprised um i do know i
think it's
how's the median sale price from last
march
through this march is up 16 and a half
percent
um and year to date it's up 19 percent
so that does fall online yeah
you can't build houses fast enough
yes okay representative
thank you i think this may be related to
that and i don't know if it's occurring
across the state
but we have an enormous uh
lack of construction labor in our
in our part of the state and we've got a
lot of
projects planned and they're big
projects and i think they managed to
bring labor from somewhere else
and are going to probably be able to
build but
all of the smaller construction groups
just can't find enough people to do
half of what they had planned to do
i have because we don't have housing for
them
it's a strange world we live in right
now
questions of most are on the real estate
transfer tax
and i think you're wise in what your
estimates are
for 22 and 23 because
it is a bubble right now
i don't see any questions
all right we're almost there um utility
property tax
uh factors to consider for this fiscal
year to date through march were half a
million or 2.1 percent ahead of plan
and we are 400 000 or 1.7
ahead of prior year some factors to
consider for this tax
is property may decline in value due to
changes in economic conditions
if any new taxable property may be
constructed
and then lastly upt doesn't appear to be
impacted by covid19
thus far that we've seen for fiscal year
21 we don't have a range on this tax
either because it doesn't tend to swing
very far in either direction we end
our fiscal year 21 estimate is 42.8
million or three percent below plan
uh this is a reduction for the remaining
months based on
reduction of utility property values
from the prior year
and then we have it flat for 22 and 23.
any questions on the utility property
tax
okay i think you have some wrap-ups to
do all right
yeah so i think our last two slides um
are just
summary slides that hopefully are just
easier for you than having to go through
each slide
it gives a summary of our fiscal year 21
low and highs with that anomalous
receivable removed and then it has our
growth ranges for 22
and 23 and then our last slide
this is just an internal document that
we used but we thought we'd share that
might be helpful it's similar
to christie's we have fiscal year 20
audited revenue we have fiscal year 21
plan
we then have the latest governor's
estimate as well as your estimate
which is pre-march data we have
our dra estimates that we gave to the
senate and they're saying that we're
giving today
which were done on the 19th those
contain march data
and then we have our growth ranges for
22 and 23
i think it's important to note on this
slide although the numbers
may vary because the base is different
for uh
for 21 with this new march data
the estimates are excuse me the
percentages
probably still fall within our
percentage so that's really
the area you want to look at for 22 and
23.
okay uh representative romney
yes uh thanks mr chair uh melissa do we
have a sense of when the senate will
have their revenue projections
done i don't think so i don't i don't i
they're gonna have us back again in may
so
um i would assume not before may if
they're having us back here in the next
couple of weeks
with the business and ind information
maybe thank you uh mr chair do you have
any sense of
what they're shooting for i'm just
curious the senate
in terms of getting their revenues done
if you ask me a question
your volume is real though
say it again no do you have a sense of
when the senate what the senate is
shooting for to get their
their senate ways and means targets done
for revenue
actually i haven't asked a
guider about that but we will be talking
later this week okay thank you
uh representative uh thank you chairman
major
thank you for taking my question um we
are getting closer to the governors
i just wanted to double check um
are all of his estimates also current
law because it seemed like
sometimes he was considering other
factors
that's a good question chris shea might
know
i think these last ones are current law
but he has his hand up so i'm going to
let him take that
thank you uh reps and major is it okay
to respond
yes um yes it's we worked with the
governor's office at the start of the
process to get
uh the base revenues to be current law
and any changes we put in a separate
section is uh changes the current law
and i have a sheet once a dra is done i
wanted to share with the committee
just to talk about real briefly based on
a couple of comments that were made
during the presentations
but yes this current law thank you
any further questions uh of
mr chairman representative schamberg
here
president uh i have a question for the
chair
uh will the dra be back next week when
we
meet
i expect that the dra will be with us
every time we meet with the revenues
and what i've done is i've scheduled web
revenues next week for wednesday
tuesday next week is going to be devoted
to work sessions on
senate bills well then
my question might be we're always trying
to get information
i wonder if the assistant commissioner
might be able to answer two questions
that i
when i read their fiscal notes
on senate bill 3 and senate bill 101
21-108 and 21-1047
i just wonder if they could just give me
an answer that
they always say there's data not
available but
uh is the reason that there's not a line
on the bpt
uh or taxpayers report their gross
business
income uh is that by rsa
is that by rule is that by i don't know
and the f e i n is that by rule that
they're not put on these forms
uh i just wonder if somebody could
answer that question carolyn
sure so the issue with respect to the
fbi ns
is that the small business
administration hasn't
given us the feins for the recipients
of the ppp loans so we definitely have
feins for all of our taxpayers on their
tax returns
but we would also need that data with
respect
to the list of loan recipients to match
them to come up with the impact
with respect to why that particular line
isn't
on the bpt tax return
um melissa can jump in if i'm incorrect
here
but it doesn't flow into the calculation
of the tax that they
owe and generally speaking um
i don't know that this is a statute but
it's a common practice
of departments of revenue we we try to
only ask for information that we
actually
need to calculate the taxpayers tax
liability
thank you assistant commissioner thank
you mr chairman
okay further questions of the dra
once more anybody have any questions
from the dra
while they're here
don't see any so chris can you share
that information with us
yeah thank you represent major so during
the presentation there was a question
about um
current revenue versus um changes to
revenue
and how that's accounted for and the
answer was provided i think by melissa
that
you'll find it on a surplus statement
that our office prepares
so if you recall the the house finance
committee put out a
presentation on april 5th and within
that document you would find
a comprehensive surplus statement broken
out by general fund and education trust
fund
and in that you would find various
adjustments to revenues
as well as to your appropriations
because we account for
bills that may have passed the body that
had an appropriation assigned to it as
well as appropriations in house bill 2
to establish what the um house's
position is
on the budget we'll continue to do the
same thing on the senate side
one of the documents that you worked on
and i'll share it right now
um
during the uh last few times that we met
was this compare document which show was
showing you your estimates compared to
the governor
and the march 18th estimates and you'll
see the top half of that
spreadsheet are the current law revenue
estimates or your base estimates
and then the bottom half of that
spreadsheet are the changes the current
law where you address house bill 2
changes
as well as other bills such as house
bill 281 which is the single sales
factor delay
and your committee made some um
suggestions on what you thought the
impacts would be
we took that information and we put it
rolled it forward
into the surplus statement i suspect
you might do the same thing as you're
going through your revenue estimates
again
you'll come up with your basic estimates
and you may look at some of the senate
bills that you
may support or not support and provide
an estimate related to that
as well as the status of some of the
positions you had
um related to the bills that you passed
maybe new information has come to light
or you feel um that you know the
estimate you made at the time should
have been
something different and we would make
those adjustments on this type of sheet
for you
so i think it was repsome southwest who
was asking the question i just wanted
the committee to know that we would help
you with that process and
um get you to a point of where you're
netting your your revenue so you see
that the bottom row is
um your base estimates against all the
adjustments you're making
gives you your new revenue estimate and
then that is carried into a surplus
statement and used against the budget
this is the most important sheet that
you have
when you do an analysis of the budget
because as chris says your current law
is what you see above and then any
changes to the
current law that's proposed in the
budget
you can see what effect it will have
then you can add the
the negative or the positive effect you
can
come up with your total line which is at
the bottom
and then if if there's something in
addition to that
that's being considered you just add
another line
yep and and one other just a
brief comment when you do your house
resolutions
it's just based on the current law so
it's this top half that is in your house
resolution
it's not the bottom half because that
gets um taken care of in the surplus
statement
the top half of this is what goes into
the back of house bill one is your
unrestricted revenues
so i just again just to clarify you know
some of the process here
and how it's done so what i foresee
doing is taking the
this middle area that has house ways and
means putting it over where the governor
estimates are and then putting your new
estimates
in here and then you could see any
adjustments you've made from your
um the the revenue estimates that are
part of your
uh proposed budget that passed over to
the senate
right any questions to ask chris on this
do you have anything else i i do not but
i see representative abrami and repson
southworth have their hands up
okay representative mr chair
uh chris so let's say we passed
sb3 yep and uh
and we know that and we have to project
our revenues for 2001 as they are
and they're going to be a lot more than
uh plan
um so that would be shown in the top
part so
would it would we then have to estimate
what we think the impact of sp3 will be
in in
22 and 23 and reverse some of that
revenue out
for those years on the um on the bottom
of that sheet you just showed us
exactly exactly here in the surplus
statement
yep um so whatev whatever um
so the next surplus statement that will
be done will be on the senate phase of
the budget
so it'll be based on the senate's
position and then that the final
will a committee a conference will be
had between the house and the senate to
iron
any differences out on the budget and
the final surplus statement would
consider
anything that you've agreed to in terms
of the base revenue estimates
as well as any um changes to law
either in house bill one or other bills
that might impact
um your revenues thank you
and so you know in terms of the ppp you
know you don't have a year by year
breakdown of that so the committee would
have the
would have to come up with some idea of
what they thought in 22 they think the
impact might be
and then in 23 what the impact might be
and
just as you did with the um single sales
factor delay where you you came up with
an estimate of 20 million dollar
gain in revenue in fiscal year um
23 as a result of that delay okay
so all right but that's the way it's
going to show though that's the key
thing is
yep yes you know we have a lot of
estimating to do though
so on the worksheet that we talked
discussed earlier you would you focus on
the idea of your base estimate you know
what what do you think revenue would be
if nothing were to change right now
right and then
you would have your discussions on okay
if we we agree with these
changes what do we think that impact
would be and do we add or
uh subtract revenue to get to a new new
number yep
sounds good thank you representative
southwood
uh thank you uh both for chairman major
and for chris
i guess the reason i brought this up is
um i've had conversations
in a number of groups where people have
focused on the top half
and how well our revenues are doing and
so on and it just seems like
people don't really understand the
implications of the second half
and the surplus statement so i just
think it'll be really important
that we tie them together you know going
forward
you know because people have thought we
were just passing on the top half so to
speak
um as our presentation to the senate and
really we weren't
we were passing along the top half
plus the possible deductions on the
surplus statement
and that's absolutely correct and and i
think another confusion that also
occurs um is that people will look at
the monthly revenue focus for instance
and say geez we're really doing great
um you know we're i'll pick a number 200
million dollars ahead of plan
but you've already considered some of
that revenue and you're estimating
so even when you're looking at you know
the fy 2021 plan
and you're reading the revenue focus
that comes out of administrative
services some of that surplus you're
seeing or that excess revenue you're
seeing
has already been accounted for in your
estimates so
so it's another confusion that occurs
and i'm not sure how you um
educate you know 400 people in in one
body and 24
in another as well as the public i mean
we do it through our briefings as much
as we can
but and we put it in all our documents
and make reference to our surplus
statement
but you're absolutely correct reps and
so forth i think there is confusion
um at times
thank you this wouldn't help with the
plan
problem but i'm wondering if we
and this would be for representative
major on
whether we could innovate on the house
resolution
and include an estimate of
of surplus statement
on it when we give it to the other
members
and to the senate
i think that's a good suggestion it
would be
an addendum to the house resolution
but it would add clarity to the total
revenue picture
representative spellsworth thank you mr
um this morning's discussion
included references to two
transfers that i don't recall previously
having heard about so
i'm trying to absorb what these are all
about
and how similar they are and whether
there are many other examples so one was
the
draw for dhhs
from the liquor commission which i
gather was 8.2 million
and the other was the draw
for the affordable housing fund five
million dollars from the real estate
uh transfer tax am i correctly
understanding these to be
unbudgeted provisions that allow
for a transfer to cover a shortfall in a
dedicated program
or or am i misunderstanding that it's
you're you're half correct um so the
affordable um housing has was accounted
for in the surplus statement when that
became statute
what happens on a cash basis the money
comes in the door and then it's
transferred to the
affordable housing fund so it will be um
reconciled you know out of the cash you
have two other instances of that
one is with the uh school building eight
debt
service that comes out of meals and
rooms so you'll see an adjustment
um on the at the end of a month for an
amount so that's accounted for in your
estimates
and it's right now it's about eight
million dollars a year
for that and then the um second is the
real estate transfer tax where a portion
of that goes to
um l-chip program so it's
roughly four million dollars four to
five million dollars a year
depending on how um how many transfers
are occurring
um and so that is comes in the door on a
cash basis but then there's a transfer
made
or it's carved out of the revenue it's
not counted towards the unrestricted
general fund revenue
the difference is with the dhhs one
so that that's unknown it's not planned
for
the language just gives them the ability
to ask liquor to make that transfer if
they need the funds but there's there's
no plan for that or no
accounting of that because there's uh at
this point no way to
assume what they might need going
forward so
you're saying that three of the four
that you've just described
are budgeted are accounted for as part
of your revenue estimates yep
okay
uh representative
thank you on chris i've been
wondering for some time whether lbao
weighs in with the finance committees
when they decide to do
something like this about the best way
to try to do it from the perspective of
the revenue committees it
makes it a lot more difficult to explain
to people what's happening to the
revenues and to ourselves
from the perspective of
of lbao and proper accounting procedures
i'm not sure where it is and whether
you try to do anything about it when
they put these things in
uh the only i just sort of think i want
to respond here
what we do is make sure that what
they're suggesting works
but we don't try to influence the policy
or the end game that's trying to be
achieved so for instance the affordable
housing the way that was set up
that's practical that that is perfectly
okay to set it up in the fashion that
they did to restrict five million
dollars a year
have it paid out um i think on or before
october first of a particular fiscal
year
um so so we don't do work with them
um to guide in that sense
but in terms of communicating with you
know ways and means and when they want
to do this
oftentimes we don't have a lot of uh
flexibility because some of these
types of things may be decisions that
occur in the last couple weeks of a
budget building process
you know maybe an idea that's been
floating around it may have been
considered in another bill
and then it gets brought into the the
budget preparation process
and so we just try to make sure it
technically works
but we don't try to say well this isn't
a good idea you really shouldn't do this
you should really have it go through
ways and means
or any other policy committee unless i
have an opinion
on that if i could
hear this that if money is
to be appropriated they should be
appropriated from the general fund
because essentially that's what you're
doing is
when you take 5 million from meals and
rooms and you take
so much from tobacco or something else
you're taking it away from fun so it's
each one of these four items should be
debated and financed and
funded the general fund rather than
saying
we're not going to go through this
legislative process we're going to give
them this money but we're going to take
it directly out of
rooms and meals and that's
muddies up the water because you don't
really it's not a
true reflection of what we raise in
rooms and meals
personally i would fight each and every
one of these
so many times with these types of
situations it's an
effort to try to dedicate a certain
amount of money to a certain
um area or function
so instead of establishing uh maybe a
new dedicated fund
in these cases there's instances of
taking revenue
and having it go directly to a
particular place
where maybe there's a fund already
established
um but i mean that's a debate i think
that um
yes uh members would need to have with
themselves again we just
make sure that the the language and
policy seems to
work the way the uh group or committee
has intended
for it to work and you do a good job
thank you yes i i might just like to
point out that one of those things
made fiscal sense i didn't like it but
we uh we had to pay for the school
bonding that was
already is obliged and on
to do that they had to have a specific
source
for the the bonding and that was
the meals and rooms revenue yeah
hey any further questions for chris
i'm roxanne tucker that's not a question
but
i think that uh right now the
there's bonding for water projects that
didn't get funded this year and uh
it's interesting that the school aid did
over a long period of time so these
things vary
depending on who's making the decisions
at the time
but i agree with you i think it's a
circumvention of the process
to have a last-minute
draw on these funds makes it very hard
for people to understand
how the system works
we did that at the in the early part of
the great recession
when we had this tail that we felt
obliged to pay for
well we have what
[Music]
respect the obligation we'll see what
the senate does
i understand that representative
um a process question uh
so at the top of our revenue estimate
worksheet we have the
official plan for fy2021
and then we've um we've we estimated
several times over the past two years
and i'm wondering if the final numbers
we come up with for 2021
become the official plan when we vote on
22 and 23
or if those always stay as we
estimated in 2019 how the official plan
is developed
it's after the budget is passed
in the department of administrative
services checks of all the agencies
and they examine each and every one of
these revenue streams
and what they do each month historically
and they come up with the best estimate
as is how much of the total
is derived in july
august september etc and that becomes an
official plan based on the budget
we don't we don't develop that we may
have some input
into it but it's the administrative
services that does that
and that sticks with us for the whole
two years everything
measured against the plan and so our
work of re-estimating 2021
that's already been officially voted on
and
right it will either be
above or below the plan is it is it an
effort to help the finance committee
spend funds by re-estimating
every couple months or so
what it does
the executive branch
will monitor how the revenues are coming
in
and if revenues are coming in lower and
they have to start
making adjustments uh they want to know
that
early in the year they don't want to
know it in
in may because it's too late yes
adjustments so so they look at what our
revenues are
against the plan because the
spending was based against the plan
does that answer your question yeah i
guess i was wondering if
um the 2021
official plan numbers um
are relevant after
june 30th of the year well they are
relevant because that's what the budget
was based upon now to
implement the budget you use that
but if the revenues are coming in less
then the executive branch has got to
stop
reducing spending in order to be able to
keep
within the budget
one more question modified by the
revenues
and new revenues one one more question
about that
um so the dra does their high and low
percentages
off of the plan numbers so
um at the end of the year well they do
their
i'm sorry they do their estimates based
upon
past performance not off the plan
okay the plan is
is only developed after the budget is
passed
and it's for that particular budget
all right you take a few months to
usually the budget will pass
by the end of june and then you won't
see the plan
for a few months right it could be three
four months
when you do the revenue focus uh for
july in august you won't see a plan when
you see their comparison against
equal month of the year prior year
okay thank you very much
like chris i was just going to add a
little bit but
generally represent major covered it
represent marlowe but
what's important about the having the 21
plan is just so as you're working on
estimates and
trying to figure out where 21 might end
up you can kind of see
where the committee two years ago
kind of thought the plan might end up in
terms of revenues
and gives you kind of a base to see you
know are we doing something
wildly crazy here compared to what we've
done in the past
um you know and is there a reason for
that you know m r you
you had a plan of 386.9 million you know
the pandemic hit and
now you're down to 311 uh
311 was what you you passed just based
on the information
so what it the intention is to give you
a sense of when you're building your
base number for 21
that you're going to build your 22 23
off from
there's no changes to the official plan
as represent major indicated
because that plan number is is basically
was used to help budget
the fiscal year 21 appropriate
appropriations
so it's good that it's uh the numbers
are much higher than what was in plan
that means that you're doing pretty well
with the the revenue and we should end
in a good position
it becomes uh much more concerning when
you're
your current year that you're in against
plan that shows a negative number
and what might be happening with trends
in your revenue
going forward you're going to going to
only see a plan for fiscal year 22 and
23.
so 21 will drop off at the end of june
thank you one more one more thing
the revenues coming in with business
taxes
is huge compared to what the plan is
and it might lead some people to say hey
we can spend more money on projects
because we have all this extra money but
they have to understand
why that money is extra and
how much of it they they want to be
careful
of saving because you may lose it in the
future
thank you this is a comment i want to
thank uh representative gamora for that
uh
process question it was a nice uh
reminder of how this whole thing works
it's
i know i've heard it before but it's
it's good to be reminded
of how um how
our job and what it is we do
helps to explain things and i would also
add that i've had the question
of what are we doing with the extra
extra
uh the the the projections of the
business profits taxes
and those revenues that are coming in so
this is helpful too
i was not really able to effectively
answer that question so that's all it's
a comment
thank you anybody else questions or
comments
then tomorrow i
tried to get two speakers tomorrow
but so far we have one we have an
economist coming in for
ten o'clock tomorrow to talk about the
new hampshire economy and where we
stand right now and then i was trying to
get an update from
treasury but we haven't had any response
there's jen on the line
she she's with uh i
i am i'm back now i was with the fishing
game
jennifer have we heard anything from uh
emily brock yeah emily no i i didn't
receive a response yet
oh boy okay so then all we have for
tomorrow
is is economist
will bring us up to date on what he
feels the new hampshire economy is doing
right now
and that's at 10 o'clock so who is the
economist
it is brian gottwa
wonderful i know just who you mean
that's terrific
so it'd be able to tell us how the
employment is going and other things
all right and then next week we're going
to deal with um
work sessions on the
seven remaining senate bills and i've
arranged them
there those have to do with lucky seven
tickets and
that sort of thing incentive bill three
lastly
and then we want to identify do any of
these
need amendments do they need more work
will we be ready to execute them
i don't plan on doing any any exacting
next tuesday
but we're going to discuss the bills and
identify those that are ready to be
exact
and what needs to be done what we need
for more information
all right is there a possibility of
executing on wednesday afternoon
i have an appointment i'll try and
rearrange it if we are
we only have seven bills and we have a
long time
uh what is we have to get them out
around the 20 something
27 27. so i i'd rather
get those in the position where we can
exact them all
at once so we're not going to i don't
plan on exactly
to get a tentative exact date so we can
all keep our
calendar free on that day
and uh we'll discuss that next week
wonderful right but i don't plan
doing anything exactly next week
wonderful
well today was very useful thank you
all right uh if nothing else then
we'll see you at 10 o'clock tomorrow
don't forget to check your emails i sent
the uh amendment
to everyone good job